[Música]
estas son las alarmas que salvan vidas
en ucrania su red es de época soviética
y ha sido adaptada a la guerra gracias a
la tecnología actual iván es el guardián
de las sirenas de jarquín
nuestros programadores desarrollaron una
app que se usa en todo el país y que
permite activar la distancia absoluta el
activa la aplicación con su teléfono
inteligente no importa el lugar ni la
hora cuando recibe información aprieta
el botón y se encienden los altavoces de
las sirenas en la región la telefónica
telecom también ha sido modernizada y
gracias a eso funciona con la app lo que
hace posible enviar rápidamente las
notificaciones a los teléfonos de la
ciudadanía la red recorre ucrania de
este a oeste pero los bombardeos han
destruido muchas terminales iván dice
que solo en su región necesitan cuatro
veces más sirenas de las que tienen las
necesitamos para cubrir la región de
jarquín que está siendo atacada todos
los días
las sirenas ucranianas siguen trabajando
sin descanso en el este de ucrania su
sonido y el de la bombas son la
permanente banda sonora de este
conflicto